basements welcome to the dynamic kill
test
Jonathan you're first you ready for this
yes sir I'm nervous
[Music]
thank you
all right Jonathan let's talk about your
fencing knife here first up the handle
here it's nice and oh void and it really
fits my hand for a grip and good
retention your Edge held up nicely no
issues nice balance
wheelability and lethality is good and
overall
you look heel
all right Felicia your turn you ready
sure let's do this since I had to
re-quench my blade a couple times the
edge might break off or roll I could win
or it could break gloriously and I could
lose
[Music]
okay then
all right Felicia let's talk about your
fencing knife here first up it's a very
light weapon that you have designed over
here I like the way it feels with the
handle here your Edge Cuts very deep
into this ballistics dummy but during
the test you have two points right here
where it took a little bit of a chip but
I like the way it feels and overall your
fancy knife
you'll kill
thanks
[Music]
all right bladesmiths Welcome to our
Dynamic strength test the fish and duck
pole chop
Jonathan you're up first you ready for
this yes sir okay
[Music]
oh
wow
dude
foreign
Jonathan your blade was cutting
beautifully it was holding up nicely but
I started to feel loosen a little bit
what really caused that break was the
pin the pin is very close to the edge of
your shaft here all that dress goes
right into the pin and or right around
the shoulder and you can see
this is where it broke
[Music]
oh we thought you're going to make it
all the way through but unfortunately
your blade did take a catastrophic
failure on the seventh strike on the
dock pull here you're not out of the
fight yet you know how this goes
completion in order to take home the
title of Fortune fire champion and get a
check for ten thousand dollars your
blade will have to survive all of these
fish and seven strikes on the poles are
you ready
sure all right Dave take it away
Here We Go Again having already taken
Edge damage I don't know if my blank can
handle some of the strikes I can totally
see my blade just shattering around the
post flying off into the water
I am not optimistic and I believe Will
Survive
everything held up
Felicia congratulations your blade made
it through all the strikes in our tests
Jonathan you're clearly a talented Smith
you fought so hard through this Mystic
Seaport challenge but unfortunately
because your blade did suffer a
catastrophic failure during your test
your time in this competition has ended
we want to say thank you for coming out
and trying so hard
thank you sir thank you Jonathan thank
you I'm very disappointed my handle
broke
but I had a wonderful time well Felicia
that means you are the new Fortune fire
Champion you are the youngest female
champion you'll be receiving a check for
ten thousand dollars well done
I'm pretty stoked yeah it's a little
more clout than I expected so that's
nice
if I can get some exposure being a woman
in a very unsaturated Market
I'm so excited this is so cool
like I won
now I can actually repay my mom and dad
for that brand new anvil